as a flight attendant people have been
curious what's flying like during the
corona virus pandemic so today we're
gonna answer some of those questions hey
my name is sue rot and I've been a
fighter in it for three years
my name is Dennis and I have been a
fight and then for three years how is
the quality of the air on planes I've
been told by some of the pilots that
there's a filtration system and the
airplane the cabin the hair is
definitely recycled then we wearing a
pressurized cabin we're not getting air
from outside there's no breathable air
at 30,000 feet but there are definitely
filters in the airplane that just
constantly recycles the air and those
filters are actually from the same grade
that they use in operating rooms and
hospitals how have the planes been
cleaned more than usual I can honestly
say I've never seen the planes cleaner
partly because there's a lot less people
and people make messes they've
definitely been ramping up the cleaning
on the planes especially because of the
situation we've always had wipes on
board like sandy calm wipes they call
them all the airlines I think have that
for the crew but now my specific airline
I don't know what the other guys are
doing this but they're giving us these
big jars of like Clorox wipes then we
can give out a request for a customer
but you have planes definitely have been
what's it like right now working as a
flight attendant right now things are
super weird
to say the least just taking everything
day by day taking it as it comes and
just keeping myself updated with current
events things are changing literally by
the hour so just keeping myself updated
it's a little different I mean the job
itself is still pretty normal I get on
board
I immediately like clean my seat belt
buckle now I wear gloves when I do
service or just in general during the
flight
now we're allowed to do that before that
wasn't really that we could we weren't
able to do that but now we are have you
been trained to handle situations like
coronavirus we have been in trained to
handle sick passengers so everything is
situational based so whatever you've got
going on will be handled accordingly as
long as you tell us the captain has a
frequency that he can tune in its called
med link it's a doctor that basically on
the ground that's up in this frequency
and the pilots would tell the doctor on
the ground what we're telling the pilot
what's happening the doctor would tell
the captain what we as a flight
attendant should be doing to make a
situation better there's a lot of
medical equipment on board
we're not nurses or doctors so we need
the permission by the doctor to like go
ahead and use it just to keep somebody
with a fighting chance until we land the
flight
I have a lot of flights been canceled
yes a lot of flights have been canceled
ins I do know that the international
carriers have been seeing more
cancellations than domestic so far my
flights have just been really light like
I've been in the elevator with more
people wait I've been canceled they've
been doing it one in advance to help the
customers experience in terms of that
but yeah I've been canceled in place I
realize any public council is there
normally there is a cancellation fee but
I do think that right now on airlines
are waiving their consultation fees
definitely double check with the airline
that you do decide to book with and just
read the Terms of condition also before
you even book if they're hand sanitizer
available on planes soap water wipes
gloves you name it
my specific airline we have the soap on
in the bathroom it's a foaming soap it
doubles as a hand sanitizer when the
waters not working
would you recommend that people bring
their own sanitizers and wipes on
flights yes I would
honest mission have been a thing before
this pandemic but yeah bring your own
wipes and I would say wipe the tray
tables the sink buckle if there's a TV
in front of your wife the TV the armrest
you stop having your babies crawl on the
floor I always cringe when I see that
and don't go into lab barefoot it does
not do that I saw one passenger wiped
down the air vent doesn't make the air
cleaner but kudos to her because that's
a surface that's often overlooked how
have some of your flights looked are
there a lot of passengers or are the
planes
empty I have been working some super
empty flights and it's been a dream
truthfully but they've been nice and
empty really like during this time of
year traveling is always uh it's not the
highest season yet and then that
combined with what we're going through
right now
yeah the planes are lighter what what's
the impact this is just the overnight
drop in demand of flying but yeah a lot
of our planes I've been
like maybe 30 50 she's opening seats
which is not normal what happens once in
a while but since airline travel deals
are dropping is your drop security being
affected well most of us are guaranteed
our hours this month whether or not the
flights canceled but next month might be
slim pickins we're back on reserve which
is essentially working on standby bases
which you still get paid you just can't
make plans you don't two days ago I
would have answered this question
differently but now I've been seeing
airlines around me just like struck
another one just like seized operations
and that's scary you know has it
happened yet to an American based
airline hopefully it doesn't happen but
this is some very impactful moment that
we're in right now the last time
something like this has happened was
9/11 and their life struggled for years
to get back to where they were prior to
it there's hiring freezes you know my
airline was hiring a lot and all their
lights too
we might be a little off for staffed
right now given the flights that are
actually leaving compared to what was
planned for the quarter definitely am
nervous vibe around my colleagues right
now in terms of what's to come like my
summer are we're going to be employed or
not it's it's going to be a very
interesting next couple of months we'll
see I would like to say just protect
yourself just stay safe we do decide to
fly think about everyone else also think
about yourself and if you're not feeling
well I think they you should stay home
stay informed check for updates if you
have a trip planned already check was
going on check of your resorts are open
check if you know just go ahead and
figure things out there Leslie
check if the place that you're going is
in a state of emergency is everything
closed is there a curfew because if
you're going there for vacation and
there's a curfew you're gonna end up
being stuck in the hotel for the whole
time you're there because you can't go
outside so thanks for watching and
washing those hands
[Music]
you